hello everyone and welcome to me trying
to defeat Magnus Carlsen V app at age 10
so let's see how this goes I know it
plays at a relatively low rating but an
engine playing at a low rating isn't
isn't the same as playing a low rated
person at least not to me it does tend
to play stronger so what I'm gonna do
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna play a
normal game and and try to try to win it
in the end game so let's see how this
goes
I'm gonna go Knight f6 there should be
seven okay let's just castle here maybe
c6 Knight B d7 okay let's go b6 there
should be seven the rook c8 and maybe it
maybe try and push c5 we'll see okay
capture capture I'll capture and go okay
can't go c5 just yet but okay what's
this can I use this somehow not really
he's going for yeah I don't want to open
up his his his dark square Bishop so I'm
gonna go h6 here yeah he's opening this
up let's just kick the Queen away from
there and I try and exchange Queens I
guess okay and maybe push c5 next if he
allows it okay let's go c5 capture
capture and let's let's try and win this
endgame lets if I go if I go Bishop f6 I
think I can go go ship f6 Knight f3 okay
let's go here you just have to exchange
I guess how does he how does he okay so
I win a pawn I like that
Bishop here okay a rook here I guess I
either push or double up so I I guess I
can push with tempo let's just push it
push further I guess lock it down and I
don't really I don't really want him to
to be able to play rook f2 so I guess
I'll go now I can't play this not yet at
least
I'll just go here okay and maybe
exchange this annoying Bishop but then
then he has Bishop e7 going for this
pawn but do I mind this not really just
capture here but I give up this strong
pawn is it worth it
how should I go about this maybe push g4
and then go for if he captures I have a
Bishop g5 yeah I guess I guess this is
worth worth the shot okay you can
capture once sure and now I go Bishop
here and pretty sure I can I can capture
here if he captures I'm just gonna pin
him okay so what am I missing here he's
gonna give up the exchange okay don't
think this was worth it just gonna go f6
and get my King into the game probably
have to defend this pawn first but this
should be winning okay just gonna put a
rock on a nice light square he attacks
it I can simply defend push f5 and g6
okay he managed one double but I don't
really care
I'll just go here try and pin him again
let's spin him again and he's is the
pawn and and and game-winning for me not
yet but if if I manage to grab this pawn
it will be
so I will grab it and okay let's just
exchange and win the game so this is
this is it I just captured that guy and
let's go here he's just gonna doesn't
really matter what I play let's go here
he's gonna protect it but now I'm just
gonna push or he's gonna go the other
way around
still doesn't matter just I'd hate it if
he managed to still meet me or something
with a we're at the pawn push okay so
let's just put the pawns it seems that
some of you said in the comments that
the app doesn't resign until I hit level
aged eleven so we'll see how that goes
okay let's push push push further so now
he's pretty much forced stay and the
first rank and let's just push this to
victory sheer and bring a nice rook into
the game for a nice checkmate so very
nice we want the game we got our we got
our stars and we received in 1998
thunder thing is very nice but only two
stars i wonder i wonder why that is why
was it too slow or something i don't
know how stars are distributed or crowns
their crowns so yeah
that was me playing against h10 hope you
enjoyed it i will get back to you after
i defeat
age 11 probably i will play tomorrow or
something so yeah that's the game i hope
you enjoyed it as usual to check two of
my previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon